Fans know to always be on the hunt for easter
eggs or hidden references, especially as shared
movie universes become more and more popular.
But who says the fun has to stop when the
movie does?
Whether they change the message, offer a laugh,
or tease something to come, these post-credits
scenes are a must-watch for movie buffs.
Here are Screen Rant's 10 Hidden Movie Scenes
You've Never Seen #2.
Kill Bill
Quentin Tarantino is famous for putting extra
work into his end credits, like saving the
Bride's actual name until the credits of Kill
Bill Volume 2.
But fans who stuck it out through the movie's
entire credits were treated to not another
reveal or inside joke, but a blooper.
Or, as much of a blooper as an eyeball being
ripped out can ever be.
The X-Files: I Want To Believe
Mulder and Scully never managed to be as successful
on film as they were in the TV show, but the
X-Files stars got a truly happy ending, assuming
fans were willing to wait for it.
The second X-Files movie didn't wrap up the
mysteries of the show, but the post-credits
scene revealed Mulder and Scully drifting
towards a tropical island, waving to the camera.
It doesn't make any sense, which makes it
even more incredible.
American Gangster
Sometimes a post-credits scene is used to
tease a sequel, or show that the ending wasn't
as final as audiences thought.
But American Gangster is a completely different
animal.
Instead of showing more of Denzel Washington's
character's fate, or the lawmen who brought
him down, they put the audience into the shoes
of his many victims.
We should all hope our last views are this
badass.
X-Men Origins: Wolverine
Wolverine's first solo movie didn't go as
fans had hoped, which meant plenty of them
probably left the theatre long before the
credits rolled.
Sadly, some of the best moments of fan service
came at the end: Logan returning to his northern
bar from the first X-Men, and even heading
to Japan, a major setting for his comic book
history - not to mention confirming his Canadian
heritage once and for all...
Wayne's World
As one of the most quotable and self-aware
movies of the 1990s, it shouldn't come as
a surprise that Wayne and Garth stuck around
until the movie's final moments.
After the movie's multiple Scooby Doo endings,
seeing the stars unsure of exactly what to
do next was the kind of weird humor fans couldn't
get enough of.
The Fast & The Furious
Long before movie fans knew to wait through
the credits for a tease of a sequel, the minds
behind The Fast & The Furious were already
hoping for a lasting franchise.
They could never have known it would become
a billion-dollar series, but the filmmakers
made sure to give Dominic Toretto a post-credits
stinger, showing he made it to Mexico after
all - a plot they picked up in the fourth
movie.
Frozen
Since it was a Disney movie, it was all but
guaranteed that Frozen would have a happy
ending - and it had one of the happiest that
any kids' movie could hope for.
But fans have to watch until the very end
to see that no character was overlooked, as
Marshmallow, Elsa's giant snow monster apparently
didn't melt with the rest of the kingdom.
In fact, he's wearing the crown of Arendelle,
hopefully giving the Queen a fight for the
throne in a coming sequel.
Ted 2
The movie is filled with celebrity cameos,
but Liam Neeson's is the strangest, trying
to buy a box of Trix cereal.
Since he knows that "Trix are for kids," he
demands Ted's word that he won't be followed,
or be given any trouble.
It's played for a laugh, but to see the joke
paid off, wait after the credits - when a
beaten and bloody Neeson returns the cereal,
staring Ted down for betraying his trust.
Wall-E
Pixar is known for its sense of humor, breaking
the movie's fiction to give easter eggs or
nods to other movies.
Wall-E didn't stray too far from its own story,
but for the final title card, Pixar's famous
mascot, Luxo the lamp, has a problem only
Wall-E can solve.
Of course, the little robot makes things worse
just as quickly as he saves the day.
Cars
Pixar's vision of a world where cars replace
people was filled with puns, gags and references
only parents would understand - but did you
know that Pixar's most famous films also exist
in the Cars universe?
Stick around for the end credits, and you'll
see clips from all of Pixar's biggest hits,
with most of their cast returning to voice
a line or two as a car counterpart to their
famous characters.
Those are the secret movie scenes and post-credits
stingers we think every fan should keep in
mind, but which ones did we miss?
Let us know in the comments, and remember
to subscribe to our channel for more videos
like this one!